all right so oftentimes when I talk
about an adhesion
and you notice
there's like some look like the person
does look kind of stuck to you okay but
then your ego tripartite mind your
material mind right your worldly mind it
now tries to find a solution that it
understands and it can only understand
things dichotomously well that's a
problem because Ike is the
reconciliation of dichotomy so there's
no way you can understand it so it's
very common
that uh you imagine that I'm using his
fingertips you see and I me and that's
what's kind of pulling him that way
but you're not
so he opens his hand I I have to find
that adhesion in the hand so I can't go
extra young and I definitely can't go
extra in I have to match that match it
match it match it match it match it
match what he's doing
if you pay attention this hand is going
to pick up
where this hand is
migrating from its young face to its Yin
face
so if you pay attention that starts to
happen here at the center line and now
the other hand which wasn't being
grabbed by anything is what does the
magnesium
so it's not much to ask of an adhesion
to go from this shoulder line to this
Center Line it's not much at all okay so
we won't have you pushed this time go
ahead and ground yourself okay so he's
not pushing all I need to do is get that
adhesion for this time to not pick up
and it will continue the techniques
which has no grout the second hand
wasn't relying on a grab do you guys
understand that okay so the first hand
is just an adhesion it moves him
so the person who let's go doesn't
matter
it's gonna adhere on the outside yes
what are you doing okay let's go I was
never dependent on their fingers in the
grab anyways so it's irrelevant I'm here
I will my brush there it is right there
same thing goes uh what so let's say
he's pulling without his grip he's
trying to go back it increases the
friction do you feel it okay because
he's increasing the young value so that
it's easier for me to stick everything
gets stickier because the young the
reconciled young value is higher so here
with no grab and he's just holding there
it let's say it's 10 but when he tries
to pull backwards it gets it's at a
hundred now do you guys there's more
as more of a sense of friction at that
part okay so it's as I said in the
previous videos the person that's just
limp okay do you get it well they're not
asking for much so even that little tilt
that I get there in that head that's
enough to keep it going
once you start him moving so you start
him moving and he moves around all right
now let's say for example
on this side
you don't have the forward progress
to go ahead and generate the adhesion as
you're working with centrifugal and
centripetal energy so like I've noticed
Tristan that you're beginning to sense
oh yeah that's a higher Yong value and I
can actually move people more do you get
it okay but it's not necessary so for
example
you understand centrifugal energy of him
going forward is Young I match it here
centripetally you're going to have like
a yawn value of 100. a young reconciled
value of a hundred you got it but this
is still young
his body sitting here is still young so
this thing still sticks
I just have to match it it still sticks
do you understand and now when it starts
to fall that too is Young descending
into Yin and you match that too
same thing here he doesn't want to come
well if he wants to get up and go the
other way
it's gonna do what
more it's going to stick more because
the yarn values more okay so he doesn't
want to come it doesn't matter the
gravity working on him is enough young
value for me to match to move
it's just I always say it's harder
that's how I describe this harder why is
it harder
it's harder because your self gets
triggered more when they're not moving
and you can't do I key from a state of
self you can only do I keep from a state
of no cell that's why it's harder so
what makes it harder it requires higher
degrees of no self that's why higher
degrees of skill at reconciling self
that's why it's harder okay if we
have a ski for example and he's not over
penetrating go ahead there's no grab
there does that mean there's no Aikido
there now it doesn't mean that right so
he goes and I hear and I adhere that's
all I get that's fine here is where I
use the other stuff you know boom
boom
so let's do an open grab no movement in
all you need is this little tilt that
was it that's all I need I'm in the
center line the other hand starts to
moving you have your forward progress
there you have your adhesion here energy
cool
all right let's see what happens right
okay so his grip is open
right and we know if you if he pulls
back on it then it increases that
adhesion value we know that right okay
so when I go like this
is he tries to drop his hand like he
lets it drop just let it dry do you get
it he lets it die do you see that all I
need is this I'll now do get on
do you understand
if he tries to pull it back what will
happen the young value will go up right
and same thing if he tries to go in now
he tries to go in towards he's trying to
go in towards him it's going away from
me the young value goes up you feel it
okay but when we're here and he dies and
goes Yin well that's where you'll get on
this so I go here he dies while I'm
picking up over here
you got it you understand okay so I I go
he dies I picked this up over here and
I'm in the same technique
okay so UK is just gonna sit there once
you feel whoa let's try to just let the
arm die and then you'll pick up the arm
with uh going over the top okay all
right
okay so on the first on the first star
we can't go up you're confused there so
you can't go up go up can't go up
lift it up can't go up okay
and you can't go back because he'll
increase the friction and he can't go
out he'll increase the friction but he
can go down do you understand and that
opens up the two Dawn here you work the
lower level okay
so once you get
to the outside right and you go here he
goes dies and you're here on the outside
again the same thing he can't come into
me because of the coke you you see do
you understand push in can't push it
he's going to lose his balance okay
uh he can he go back what do you think
he'll increase the friction do you see
that if he goes forward he'll increase
the friction he can only go that way do
you say because he can only go in the
cross to the young contact
got it so he can he can only go that way
so he goes that way and then he just
gave you his back
[Music]
hair he counters I pick it up over here
he counters again and then thank you
very much
okay
let's try that so you guys got to do
this too dead counters okay try
okay there's something to note it's not
visible on camera and really only the
okay can feel it
so even when he's just here and he's uh
not giving any energy and his hand is
just uh I already matched the young
value right and that's our young value
here and so the tonden fields are going
to be connected so I move I can move him
at his Center I'm not in his arm not
trying to move his arm not slapping his
arm at hyper young okay so whatever he
grabs with I match it and now now I have
the center okay so what I mean by that
take away your hands
if he pushes on me what's gonna happen
to the overall reconciled young value
it's gonna go up do you see that so he
can't he can't go forward because the
Coq is there okay uh but it all stays
the same it's just at a lower value well
I touch here I'm in his Center and that
is why when I come here like that I
don't just move his arm or move his arm
that I'm moving that bot that center
part and so he feels that and he tries
to get off of it and same thing here I'm
not just moving his arm I'm gonna touch
that Center that's why he's stepping
so uh put your leg back down and we'll
get here okay don't step Don't Step
don't step
he falls so he steps okay so here he
counter I picked up the new counter
encounters again and now we're here okay
so look at it this way your your hard
work is as you're moving through your
phases everything's going to be at your
Center Line so when I go and he counts
it that hand is right there already you
see and he's losing his balance so he
steps he pulls off the counter the
Honda's there right when he does it so
you I'll make sound effects so you
understand
sticks can you see that
he counted
right he counters
get stuck there you get it it's not like
this he goes well he counters oh
and I try to go like that and he puts
his arm inside and then I go like that
it all happens seamlessly
so no one would even noticed that he
tried to counter the technique you just
move to the next adhesion Point okay
your techniques are
organized in a way for that
okay it does that
it has to do with the consensual the
piss to me I always talk about
um
so get on chewed on Joe Don is part of
that Triune cosmology there's not really
three levels there's only one level at
the internal level there's only one
thing it's just that adhesion part okay
so you go one two three you're still
operating at the three things that are
not three things they're supposed to be
one thing okay so also another important
part to note even though there's an I
key at this angle Coq will be present at
the other angle of the Cross you are
rotating
okay and that's why uh as I'm trying to
go even though I'm going in on the other
side of the Cross you can't push in you
can't push in you can project when you
feel that okay
so same thing if I'm operating at the
level of conden here
same thing my UK is just kind of being a
lump I'm not gonna tilt him
I'm touching and I'll move his Center
do you think
same thing here a lot of UK want to just
fall for years so they want to Pivot on
that inner knee they go there and they
pivot you see that no no no no practice
make your UK have to move that center
around
same thing goes on the throw
so I'm gonna I'm pulling on the center
because I have a center same thing goes
on the throat most you can't want to
fall right here on that back break fall
doesn't just fall over in all the other
videos we've been posting okay so you're
in the center in his Center whoa I want
to move him again oh where we have him
again
is that it you're always in the center
right